i was watching you in the jackass movie
i was watching the jackass movie the new
one and i'm like oh [ __ ] there's machine
gun kelly
standing there with the jackass crew and
i'm like what the [ __ ] is he doing he's
gonna [ __ ] himself up he's on such a
career role i mean everything seems
perfect now you're gonna let those guys
[ __ ] with you and and sure enough they
take a giant hand and they're smacking
you in the head with it
i'm like this guy's going to get himself
killed you know what i mean
my favorite part of that was they were
like uh
like it you know they were they were
like oh it's not going to feel like
anything and it smacked me into like
what was the coldest pool i've ever felt
and i got out and i was like
it hits so it hurts so it's like it hit
you so hard they're like ah yeah well
you know we tested it on another guy but
it didn't hit like it didn't hit hard
enough to make a fly off so we like
loaded in like four times as much
nitrogen or whatever to make it slap
harder so
you said to the guys on jackass give me
the full treatment don't treat me like a
celebrity
don't treat me like a non-jackass guy if
you're going to do something to me i
really want you to [ __ ] me up and they
[ __ ] you up they did exactly what you
asked i was originally supposed to be in
that mime sketch with the snake that
like you had to be silent while the
snake came up and bit your lip i was
really glad the scheduling didn't work
out for that one